You are amazing at your job,...
...and so one day you had an epiphany.
Why am I working for some other dude who I don't even like that much...
...when I can start my own business?
Congratulations!
You're an entrepreneur.
Wait, hold it right there, muchacho.
Starting a business doesn't actually make you an entrepreneur.
And like many so-called entrepreneurs,...
...you'll soon find yourself working 15-hour days.
You'll be hiring the wrong people...
...and getting frustrated trying to manage them.
And you won't know how to fix the systems that make a great business grow.
Suddenly, you realize you didn't create a business.
You really just created yourself a new job,...
...and this new job kinda sucks.
Here's the problem.
The first thing you should have asked yourself is:...
..."Am I actually an entrepreneur?"
Because not everyone is.
Yeah, see, people generally fall into one of three buckets.
Technicians, people who are good at doing the work,...
...managers, people who are good at managing the systems people work in,...
...and entrepreneurs, people who love building new opportunities out of, well, nothing.
Now, most people fall into the first two categories, right?
Like take Mike for example.
The reason Mike wanted his own shop was because he was a great cupcake baker.
But then he found out a very hard lesson.
When a technician tries to be a manager or an entrepreneur, it just doesn't work.
So if you want to start a business, first decide what kind of person are you,...
...then find partners who can help you in the other areas.